vamos a dejar el mundo de los
recolectores y de los cazadores para
entrar en el mundo de las vajillas así
que vamos a hablar acerca de dos
productos vamos a hablar acerca de tazas
y de platos así que en este eje tengo
tazas y en este otro eje tengo platos y
vamos a suponer también que tenemos un
productor llamado alfredo si alfredo
concentra todo su tiempo en producir
tazas produciría 30 tazas entonces voy a
poner las etiquetas 10 20 30 y se
concentra todo su tiempo va a ser 30
tazas y también vamos a poner las
etiquetas de los platos 10 20 30 y bueno
entonces les decía que si tienen que
concentrar todo su tiempo en hacer tazas
va a ser 30 tazas mientras que si
concentra todos su tiempo en hacer
platos va a ser 10 platos y ahora que ya
tenemos estos 2 puntos vamos a unirlos
con una línea recta ya esta línea que
tiene que ser recta le vamos a llamar la
frontera de posibilidades de producción
lineal y para no usar todo este nombre
que es muy largo y resumirlo un poco voy
a usar sus siglas es decir pp
y en este caso está en línea recta va a
ser el pp l para alfredo ahora bien
pensemos en su coste de oportunidad y
como el pp l es lineal entonces sus
costes de oportunidad no cambia la
pendiente de esta recta no cambia no es
una curva arqueada como la que vimos en
el diagrama del cazador recolector y por
lo tanto esto nos dice que vamos a tener
un coste de oportunidad fijo y para
entenderlo mejor vamos a fijarnos en los
puntos extremos aquí él produce 30 tazas
y si produce 30 tazas cuál es su coste
de oportunidad para producir 10 platos
bien pues para producir estos 10 platos
va a tener que renunciar a producir 30
tazas así que el coste de oportunidad de
producir 10 platos es lo mismo que
producir 30 tazas y bueno si lo que
queremos hacer es sacar el coste de
oportunidad para sólo un plato pasamos
el 10 dividiendo y me queda que un plato
es igual a 3 tazas y creo que esto
parece ser suficientemente claro pero
mejor vamos a pensar en nuestro
escenario o mejor se me ocurre en otro
productor en este mercado de vajillas
voy a poner otro productor que se llama
agar si gavi concentra todos
y producir tasas va a producir 10 tazas
en un día y se concentra todo su tiempo
en producir platos va a producir 30
platos en un día y uniendo estos dos
puntos vamos a obtener esta línea recta
que va a ser el pp l para gaming
recuerden es la frontera de producción
de posibilidades lineal y bueno todo
esto porque lógicamente vamos tras el
coste de oportunidad y de hecho lo que
quiero en este momento es el coste de
oportunidad de gabi pero el coste de
oportunidad de platos y vamos tras el si
gavi hace 10 tazas entonces tiene que
renunciar a producir 30 platos por lo
tanto en este caso el coste de
oportunidad de gabi va a ser de 30
platos es igual a 10 tazas y ya con esta
igualdad si lo que queremos obtener es
el coste de oportunidad para un solo
plato lo que tenemos que hacer es
dividir entre 30 así que dividiendo me
queda que un plato es lo mismo que 10
entre 30 que es un tercio en un tercio
de taza ahora que ya tenemos los dos
costes de oportunidad los podemos
comparar y esto es muy importante porque
el coste de oportunidad que tiene
alfredo para producir un plato es de
tres tazas mientras que gabriel
la oportunidad que tiene para producir
un plato es de un tercio de taza así que
si estamos hablando de términos de taza
comparación de platos en este caso para
gaby sería mucho más barato producir un
plato que lo que lo es para el fred o
gabi tiene un costo de oportunidad mucho
más bajo que el que tiene alfredo
produciendo platos porque si nos damos
cuenta el mismo plato alfredo lo produce
por tres tazas y ella por un tercio de
plato ya esto se le conoce como que gaby
tiene una ventaja comparativa en este
caso en platos vamos a decir que gaby
tiene una ventaja comparativa en platos
a comparación de alfredo y esta ventaja
comparativa lo vamos a entender con más
claridad en el siguiente vídeo pero ojo
esto no quiere decir que ella pueda
producir más platos no estamos
refiriéndonos a que ella puede producir
más platos en un día ojo si nosotros
hablamos de eso estamos hablando de una
ventaja absoluta pero en el siguiente
vídeo voy a hablar de esto con más calma
no comandancias gabi tiene una ventaja
comparativa porque su coste de
producción es más
me refiero al costo de oportunidad que
tiene a gabi al obtener un plato en
términos de tasa sin embargo también hay
otra forma de pensarlo qué tal si esta
vez calculamos la ventaja comparativa
pero ahora vamos a hablar en términos de
tasas es decir vamos a despejar a las
tasas entonces en el primer caso que voy
a obtener como quiero despejar las tasas
las voy a poner primero y me queda que
tres tazas es igual a un plato o dicho
de otra manera el coste de producción de
una taza es lo mismo que un tercio de
plato ahora vamos a fijarnos en gaby
gabi en un principio tenía que 10 tazas
es lo mismo que 30 platos recuerden que
lo único que estoy haciendo es poniendo
las tazas primero porque lo que quiero
es despejar las tazas y ahora lo que voy
a hacer es dividir entre 10 y me queda
que una taza es lo mismo que 3 platos
por lo tanto el costo de producción de
gabi para producir una taza en términos
de platos son 3 platos y obviamente ya
habíamos hablado de esto antes el
incremento en el costo de oportunidad de
una unidad dada también tiene el nombre
de costo marginal el costo marginal en
este caso de una taza y bueno lo que
queremos saber es quién es el que tiene
la ventaja compara
pero esta vez en tazas por lo tanto lo
que nos vamos a fijar es que es el que
tiene el coste de producción más bajo si
se dan cuenta alfredo tiene el costo de
producción de una taza por un tercio de
plato mientras que gaby tiene un costo
de producción de una taza por tres
platos por lo tanto la ventaja
comparativa en tazas en este caso va a
beneficiar alfredo la ventaja
comparativa de las tasas le va a
corresponder al buen alfredo lo que
vamos a ver desde aquí hasta el final
del vídeo es qué pasa si los dos
especializan en sus ventajas
comparativas correspondientes con esto
van a poder obtener resultados que estén
más allá de cada una de sus fronteras de
producción de posibilidades lineales así
que vamos a intentar que ellos logren
obtener 15 tazas y 15 platos y esto sin
abandonar sus propios recursos así que
vamos a ver cómo efectivamente pueden
hacerlo como ya hemos dicho alfredo
tiene una ventaja comparativa en tasas
es decir un tercio de un plato a
comparación de tres platos así que vamos
a especializar lo en tazas y bueno por
el mismo motivo
gaby va a especializarse en platos
entonces que es especial
tazas quiere decir que va a ocupar todo
su tiempo en producir tazas así que va a
producir 30 tazas todos los días
mientras que si gavi se especializa en
platos lo que quiere decir es que va a
concentrar todo su tiempo en producir
platos por lo tanto va a producir 30
platos todos los días ahora vamos a
imaginar lo siguiente vamos a pensar que
cada uno se especializa en sus
respectivos productos pero no quieren
quedarse solamente aquí sino que además
lo que quieren es tener algún tipo de
combinación de los productos por lo
tanto van a decidir comerciar y para
ello van a tener que fijar un precio
justo el precio que voy a suponer
ahorita es una taza es igual a un plato
pero esto lo estoy suponiendo yo ellos
pueden quedar en el acuerdo que quieran
ahora bien este precio tiene sentido
para cualquiera de los dos porque este
precio es mucho más bajo que su coste de
oportunidad y para entenderlo mejor
vamos a fijarnos en cada uno de ellos
alfredo a gastar todos sus recursos en
hacer 30 tazas sin embargo antes se
gastaba tres tazas para obtener un plato
esto es lo que habíamos obtenido cuando
hablábamos del coste de oportunidad sin
embargo ahora para obtener un plato
solamente va a necesitar una taza porque
está comercial
y por lo tanto le conviene porque se
redujo la cantidad de tasas para obtener
un plato muy bien pero qué es lo que va
a pasar con gaby ahora vamos a fijarnos
en gaby gabi va a gastar todos sus
recursos en obtener 30 platos brillantes
el coste de oportunidad decía que para
obtener una taza necesitaba tres platos
sin embargo comerciando va a ser muy
fácil porque con un plato para obtener
una taza y por lo tanto comercial
también la comida bastante porque con un
plato va a obtener una taza y entonces
reduce la cantidad de platos que
necesita por tazas y bueno acabamos de
ver que comercial les conviene a ambos y
si lo hacen cada uno de ellos por
ejemplo alfredo continuará
intercambiando tazas por platos y podrá
terminar en cualquier punto de esta
línea que estoy dibujando aquí mientras
que gaby va a poder intercambiar tazas
por platos y también va a caer en algún
lugar de esta línea que estoy dibujando
aquí pero evidentemente en donde acaben
va a depender de cuánto quieran
comerciar
el uno con el otro porque digamos que en
el mejor de los escenarios que en llegar
al punto de 1515 que está justo aquí y
en este caso alfredo va a poder
intercambiar 15 tazas por 15 platos y
gabi va a poder intercambiar 15 platos
por 15 tazas
a una situación que era inalcanzable
dada sus propias posibilidades de
producción pero bueno espero que este
vídeo te haya servido para entender las
ventajas del comercio